hello to mr. chin thanks for joining us
what did you think when you heard the
Prime Minister last night well let me
make a point and I'm counted I guess and
challenge the idea of division this is
not a political statement as a statement
of law the lockdown restrictions are in
place separately in each of the four
nations of the UK so we've all got a
legal responsibility to assess them and
make judgments about what can be eased
and pork can and divide us me be
spreading excite the different rates and
different parts of the UK so it is
entirely possible for us to come to
different decisions for perfectly
justifiable reasons the Prime Minister
last night apart from things like border
control was talking about lifting
restrictions in England I have to meet
judgments about what's right for
Scotland I at this stage think it would
be too risky to ease restrictions
because the vilest way with me progress
against it is not sufficiently under
control yet that progress we've made is
fragile and I think it's really
important to err on the side of caution
and be very careful so we are those one
change in Scotland yesterday which is
you can no exercise outside as often as
you like as long as you speak second mr.
chin if you would be good morning
so more from the Prime Minister in
Parliament and later this afternoon
sorry about that mr. chin the health
secretary just arrived in telling us we
will hear more from the Prime Minister
later on I'm sure that you will be very
keen to hear what he has to say give a
message to Scotland which is apart from
essential practices to stay at home
that's the public health advice in
Scotland at this stage and the essential
prophecies are essential work good note
for sudra medicine and good note for
exercise as long as you stay away from
people in other households and I think
there's a duty on all of us as leaders
to be very clear about the advice we're
giving that is a duty the I bid in
Scotland and it's a duty the Prime
Minister beers in England and I think he
has to be careful to make it clear that
when he's talking about lockdown
restrictions he is talking about England
and nor about wheels Northern Ireland
and Scotland of course it's really
important that we continue as much as
possible but it is entirely possible and
perhaps necessary for us to be on so
that the different timelines were seeing
similar things in other countries in
Germany and Italy for example where
there is differences in different parts
of the country depending on the state of
the virus at the time there are many
Scots who are listening to you this
morning though who are very keen to get
back to work not least because their
money is running out but we are
absolutely not going to encourage people
to go back to work before there is
confidence about the safety of what
places and confidence that we are not
putting people at risk of getting the
virus and becoming seriously unwell so I
am as anxious as anybody to get the
economy restarted we are discussing with
different sectors here in Scotland the
guidance that will be required in order
to return safely and we want that to be
as quickly as possible but I keep saying
because I think it is right that we at
this stage must err on the side of
caution the worst thing we could do for
everybody and for businesses included
would be to move too quickly No see the
violence and fighters run out of control
again and then in a couple of weeks find
ourselves having to have more straight
at restrictions rather than being in a
position of easing them so I make no
apology right now as first minister with
a heavy responsibility to try to protect
the population of Scotland as much as I
can
I make no apology for being careful and
cautious as we tried to bring the
country out of this lockdown situation
sure and I certainly wouldn't want that
burden on my shoulders
first secretary but First Minister
forgive me but what about countries like
I don't know Sweden and Singapore we've
managed to keep their schools open
throughout and yet at the United Kingdom
and many other countries have decided
not to I'm sure that you've you've
turned you that you'll face that way and
you've wondered why they've managed to
do that what have you gathered from that
example is is not without controversy
and all countries have to reach their
own judgments we're looking but if
closely examples from other countries
know particularly as countries that are
ahead of us in the inflation curve start
to ease restrictions the people the
Scottish Government published last week
have some evidence in it that came from
Denmark six feelings of opening schools
again so we we look at all of this
international experience but
fundamentally we have to be driven by
the data in our own countries and a
prior best judgment to that data none of
these decisions are easy that all
complex I'm not sure there are any
absolute rights and wrongs when you're
dealing with that situation as
unprecedented as this but all of us are
trying to do the best we can and making
these difficult judgments and coming to
these very complex balances I'm sure
that's true Boris Johnson I I certainly
know it's true of the Scottish
government here in Scotland and we must
make these judgments on a clear basis of
decision making
prioritizing public health but also your
right to see been very aware of all of
the other harms that the way in which we
are tackling the virus through lock down
are doing and trying to balance and
mitigate all of that as much as possible
the tourism industry is going to take
quite a beating isn't it it's important
to the whole of the UK
it's very important to people in
Scotland we hearing from Dominic Rob he
was giving us a bit more flesh on the
bone today saying that potentially pubs
and restaurants could open as early as
the 4th of July in England he would like
that to be in the whole of the United
Kingdom do you think that's impossible
the only sense of key right now is I
don't know whether that date will be
possible let me say that the tourism
industry is hugely important in Scotland
chote economy but also terror reputation
and brand as a country and hugely
valuable a that sector and all of its
diversity and variety so I want to get
pubs and restaurants said that the
tourism sector more generally up and
running as quickly as possible but I
will not do any favors to any of these
businesses if we ease restrictions
prematurely and allow the virus to run
out of control again because then we'll
find ourselves a lockdown for longer so
we need to balance all of that carefully
and be guided by the best possible data
and these are the decisions we will take
step by step over the next few weeks I
don't want these restrictions to be in
place for a single minute longer than
they have to be but they must be in
place for as long as it is necessary to
get this virus under control so that we
can then start to ease restrictions but
keep her under control through a mix of
continued social distancing to some
extent that's going to be with us for
some time and also tactics like pastries
and isolate so it's really important
that we do these things as quickly as
possible but not too quickly and that we
do them carefully every step of the way
and the 14 days quarantine at the
airport's how's that going to work for
you and your fellow Scots well you know
these the issues are in border control
are for the UK government to tea I
support that and I do think is we
suppress this virus and start to open up
again we have to be careful about not
bringing in from other places again
these are things none of us want to have
to be in place that will have a big
ongoing implications that are to dizzle
sector but it's really important that we
through different means continue to
suppress the virus we until we get a
vaccine or treatment or find that there
is immunity and move antibody testing
that can tell us that
we will have to learn to live with this
virus and that will involve is doing all
sorts of things that we would never just
a few months ago have contemplated but
we've seen in the last few weeks the
tallest virus can take in the loss of
life and particularly its impact on
older people so suppressing it has to be
a priority the challenge for all of us
now is to find the ways of doing that
while still bringing a semblance of
normality back to our everyday lives and
that's got to be done carefully but
absolutely nobody is more anxious than I
am in Scotland to get that normality
back into our everyday lives as quickly
as possible what's been the most
challenging parts of lockdown for you as
a person as a citizen like everybody
else it's not being able to see my my
family my my own parents my sister my
niece and nephews my mother-in-law is 90
and you know vulnerable that's really
difficult for all of us as First
Minister the way of responsibility of
trying to get these decisions as ready
as possible knowing that there's no
certainties in this and mistakes
inevitably be will be made along the way
but you know beating that responsibility
is everybody in a position of leadership
is doing right now of knowing how
important these decisions are because
you know it's not been dramatic or
exactly check to see that the atom
attitude of life and death and that is a
heavy responsibility that I'm very a
weed or very single D it's good to talk
to you and keep well thanks for taking
the time we appreciate it